well we begin with some exciting sports
news today the 17th
wnba all-star game is taking place right
here in las vegas
kevin martin that's right joins us live
from the michelob ultra arena
previously known as the mandalay bay
event center with more hey kevin
well hey guys we are getting closer and
closer to tip
off of the wnba all-star game you can
see the fans actually
most of them are already inside the
arena getting ready for tonight's game
very exciting 24 of the league's best
players face off here today including
four
las vegas aces asia wilson and chelsea
gray for team usa
derek hamby and liz cambage for team
wmba
and you know all-star games are
typically a chance for players to have
some fun and
show off a little bit but this year
tonight's contest
won't just be about show as team wnba
will be facing team usa
which is preparing for the tokyo
olympics chelsea and asia spoke about
the added competitiveness
and facing their teammates dearik and
liz
i think it's going to be a little bit
more competitive than past all-star
appearances
you know there's a little chip on the
shoulder for both teams
want to compete the all-star team want
to compete against the usa team
it's an opportunity to do that and then
we're preparing for the olympics so
it's going to be a great all-star great
for the fans for people to come out and
support as well
uh it's gonna be exciting uh it's gonna
be fun i'm glad they're
glad dee got her first all-star man uh
it's big time congratulations to her
liz liz's liz that's who she is but
we're excited to play against them all
honestly
and i was just inside the arena a little
bit ago on the court and
the it was so exciting the fans you
could feel the energy
mark davis of course the owner of the
raiders and the owner of the las vegas
aces was in the house
sitting courtside a lot of fun the who's
who right now of
who's in the nba and nba who's in the
house tonight of course
we'll keep you live coverage right here
on channel eight coming up in five and
six reporting live kevin martin 8 sports
now
all right thanks very much kevin